estas son escenas que no se veían en
China desde 2020 Durante los últimos
días los servicios de emergencias en
Shanghai se han visto saturados los
trabajadores de la salud convierten los
pasillos en salas de tratamiento para
acomodar a tantos pacientes como sea
posible la mayoría son ancianos y
necesitan apoyo respiratorio a dos
semanas del fin de la estricta política
covid ahora el país se enfrenta una ola
sin precedentes del virus afuera del
hospital esta mujer no sabe a dónde
llevar a su esposo
no me quedan fuerzas su fiebre no baja
las autoridades de Shanghai han
establecido unas 2.600 clínicas de
fiebre para hacer frente al aumento de
casos positivos en este el número de
pacientes se ha multiplicado por 20 en
tan solo unos días
le estoy recetando medicamentos
antiinflamatorios para tratar sus
síntomas
no podemos quedarnos Aquí no hay cama
hay muy pocos médicos en este hospital y
están abrumados las calles de la capital
económica de China vuelven a estar
desiertas y los pocos que se aventuran a
salir apenas pueden reconocer su ciudad
está claro que la epidemia es grave
muchas personas están trabajando desde
casa Mientras que otras están enfermas
las funcionarios de la salud de China
estiman que unos 37 millones de personas
se contagiaron de covid en Solo un día
durante la última semana contribuyendo a
los 248 millones de casos registrados
desde el comienzo de diciembre casi un
quinto de la población China